the world of George Lucas's Star Wars is
a well of inspiration for videogames and
in the nearly 40-year history of the
franchise there have been over a hundred
games released across consoles handhelds
PCs and mobile devices some are
considered classics in their respective
genres and well some are perhaps best
forgotten
[Music]
following the series humble beginnings
on the Atari 2600 Lucasfilm finally
broke out LucasArts its own game
division in 1990 it took a few years
before began to ship its own Star Wars
games blasted games in the entire series
sadly LucasArts time has passed in 2013
Disney purchased Star Wars and handed
over the reins to Electronic Arts with a
new series of films on the way from Fame
director JJ Abrams there are no doubt
plenty of star war games look forward to
but regardless what happens in the
future the past belongs to the fans it
all began back in 1982 with the second
movie on a console far far away the
Atari 2600 the first Star Wars game was
created not by Lucas Films early game
division but by Parker Brothers 1982 the
Empire Strikes Back dropped you into
battle on the frigid planet of Hoth your
one and only goal was to defend the
secret rebel base for massive
four-legged juggernauts known as a t-80s
it was a simple recreation of the iconic
scene from the film but more importantly
it was the first interactive Star Wars
experience that players could enjoy at
home
a year later Parker Brothers followed up
with 1983 s return in the Jedi Death
Star battle it was another simple
shooting game but this time you got to
man the iconic Millennium Falcon and
shoot down TIE fighters while chipping
away at the Death Star before delivering
the final blow to the reactor core
destroying the Death Star and Vader once
and for all that same year Parker
Brothers also released Jedi arena it
attempted to recreate the excitement of
fighting with lightsabers but with
stationary Jedi and abstract combat the
results were unfortunately underwhelming
ultimately it was the port of Ataris own
Star Wars arcade game that defined the
true star wars experience on the 2600
the original arcade release featured
vector graphics and digitized voices
delivering a revolutionary and
influential experience for the time not
all of these elements made it to the
home release but Atari was able to
retain the core gameplay which was a
major step up from previous games set in
the Star Wars universe it was also the
first game based on a new hope the first
film in the original trilogy
tari took Star Wars back to the arcades
in 1984 but it left over the Empire
Strikes Back and instead went straight
into Return of the Jedi Jedi would
forego the model of the first game in
favor of an isometric on Rails shooter
that recreated numerous scenes from Jedi
including the speeder bike chase on
Endor and the Millennium Falcon's
assault on the Death Star
finally in 1985 Atari went back and
closed out the trilogy releasing the
Empire Strikes Back update for the first
arcade game which once again took
players back to Hoth for another go at
defending the rebel base from Imperial
forces and massive 80 80s
by the late 80s Atari was flagging in
the console market but Nintendo's 8-bit
system was on the rise making it the
perfect candidate for a new Star Wars
game in 1987 Namco brought Star Wars to
the Famicom the Japanese version of the
NES Namco's interpretation of the story
wasn't entirely accurate but the game
itself was simple and fun it introduced
Star Wars fans to the world of
side-scrolling platformers which would
become the predominant genre for the
series over the next few years
finally in 1991 North America got its
own Star Wars game on the NES courtesy
of JVC and Lucasfilm games from Tatooine
to the Death Star Star Wars a new hope
was a more faithful interpretation of
the original film apart from Luke using
a lightsaber in combat something which
never happened in the first film GBC
came back a year later with Empire
Strikes Back it mixed platforming
side-scrolling shooting and for the
first time lightsaber on lightsaber
action but again JVC dropped the ball
what the hell is Luke doing with a red
lightsaber anyway at that point the
Super Nintendo was on the scene and sure
enough Star Wars made an appearance
there two three to be exact
sculpted software and LucasArts
recreated the original trilogy on the
SNES between 1991 and 1994 their games
featured huge detailed sprites and some
of the best sound effects in any Star
Wars game to date they were primarily
action platforming games but thanks to
the super Nintendos mode 7 you also got
the chance to pilot luke's land speeder
in an x-wing including other iconic
vehicles and pseudo 3d sequences but
before the super trilogy concluded Lucas
arts created its first solo Star Wars
project for the PC in 1993 the legendary
space combat game xwy it was one of the
first Star Wars games to achieve
critical and commercial success and
after two expansions Lucas arts creating
the sequel in 1994 TIE fighter TIE
fighter used a new rendering engine and
offered a unique perspective on the
conflict between the rebels and the
Empire allowing you to fight for the
dark side for the first time Lucas arts
capped off the miniseries with x-wing
vs. TIE fighter in 1997 concluding the
x-wing trilogy at the same time that it
was developing its series of dedicated
space combat games Lucas arts was also
busy crafting rebel assault and rebel
assault - thanks to the advent of cd-rom
technology Lucas arts was able to use
pre-rendered 3d environment models and
full motion video the filmic experiences
were special at the time when gay
we're struggling to break free through
floppy disks and into the realm of
high-capacity CD storage impressively
that's not all LucasArts had up its
sleep not one to let a trend passer by
LucasArts was also working on dark
forces a first-person shooter in the
vein of doom the 1997 sequel dark forces
2 took a model of the first game and ran
with it
it was the first multiplayer game for
the series and players were finally
allowed to go head-to-head with
lightsabers kill me dark forces 2 also
allows you to switch between 1st and 3rd
person views which is an unusual feature
for any game at the time LucasArts was
steeped in PC development in the mid 90s
but in 1996 he returned to consoles
shortly after the release of the
Nintendo 64 with shadows of the Empire
his third-person action game took place
between the storylines of The Empire
Strikes Back and The Return of the Jedi
you played as a smuggler - render and
assisted Luke and the rescue of Princess
Leia from the grip of Prince size or
shadows wasn't as good as LucasArts
other Star Wars games of the day but it
was nonetheless a commercial success in
1997 LucasArts did the unthinkable and
released a Star Wars fighting game for
the PlayStation titled Star Wars masters
of tarrasque a scene fighting game
enthusiasts loads the game's rough 3d
engine and Star Wars fans bought at the
mistreatment of lightsabers which were
incapable of cutting close or severing
limbs a few months before George Lucas
unleashed Star Wars Episode one
LucasArts and factor 5 work together to
release Star Wars Rogue Squadron on the
Nintendo 64 in Windows PCs it featured
arcade style action across 16 levels
that tapped into many of the film's
iconic locations and the console version
was one of the first games to use a
Nintendo 64's Ram expansion pack for
high-resolution graphics LucasArts also
managed to hide a secret code within the
game that unlocked the Naboo Starfighter
from the Phantom Menace which was only
revealed to the public after the first
film hit theatres the following year the
release of the Phantom Menace was a
major turning point for the Star Wars
franchise and it had a significant
impact on the games that followed in the
years to come
stay tuned a game spot for part two of
our history of star wars video games
where we tackle games inspired by
Lucas's prequel trilogy legos and of all
things hot dance moves